[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
salut tout le monde on repart
aujourd'hui pour un petit t sujet ce
coup-ci on va complètement changer
d'époque avec un spécial super-héros
quand on parle de séries de super-héros
on pense surtout en général aux séries
des années 90 par exemple l'excellente
série Batman dont j'avais déjà parlé
scénarisée par Pauli le même qui a
scénarisé arkamasilom ou Arham City
série Batman qui a en plus inventé des
choses hein comme par exemple le n
d'arley Quinn dans la même époque chez
DC on trouve aussi la série Superman ou
la série Justice League qui sont aussi
deux excellentes séries chez Marvel dans
le même temps on trouvera des trucs
sympas Spider-Man X-Men et cetera qui
sont aussi deux très bonnes séries même
si selon moi ça vaut pas la série Batman
alors avant de commencer de parler des
vrais super-héros hein ceux qui étaient
dans les comics on va d'abord commencer
par parler de ceux qui nous faisaient
chier on va commencer par parler de
Captain
planette plan
[Musique]
bah arrête j'ai compris là c'est bon
captaine planè donc où les aventures de
C adolescents venus des quatre coins du
monde à qui Gaia la déesse de la Terre a
confié C anneaux pour sauver la planète
de la pollution ah franchement je
déteste ces séries qui essayent de vous
faire faire des choses je veux dire
c'est bon quoi ça va on est tous un peu
responsable quand même
oh et donc chaque épisode se déroule
selon le même schéma méchant par que
c'est un
[Musique]
méchantup déjà personne ne pollue juste
pour polluer ça aucun sens les planéires
essayent de l'arrêter mais n'y Arve pas
en même temps je pense que g A S choisi
les mecs les moins compétents du monde
comme dans cette épisodeù il y a un
nuage polluant qui attaque un
bus moi je prétends que ce né pas
naturel comment tu sais parux
[Applaudissements]
essayer de tuer des gamins dans un bus
scolaire en cassant les
essieux bref dans l'ordre du scénario de
chaque épisode après quelques minutes il
appppelle Captain Planet qui arrive et
ben le méchant et ta dame c'est fini
voilà donc ça c'était la construction
standard de la plupart des épisodes de
Captain Planet bon là encore ça va le
problème c'est quand les auteurs
commencent à s'intéresser à des sujets
que visiblement ils ne maîtrisent pas du
tout parlons de cette chose merveilleuse
mais totalement interdite qui est la
drogue l'épisode commence donc avec un
jeune homme qui court dans les rues et
une voix off qui nous explique ben qu'il
vient de déménager dans une nouvelle
ville et que c'est un peu dur quand même
parce qu'il connaît personne et que
doncog oh ça c'est l'intro la plus
rapide deun problème que j'ai jamais vu
quoi je veux dire attendez la drogue
c'est une pente c'est une accumulation
de problème qui te conduise à tomber
là-dedans c'est pas juste
genre je trouve plus mes clés je
trouve plus mes clés non non
non en plus c'est pas gen il commence
doucement c'est direct je vais voir le
ramutant au coin de la rue et je prends
le sac de pilu jeun qui brille donc
ensuite on retrouve la blonde qui était
en fait la cousine du type qu'on a vu
juste avant et qui à cause de la drogue
maintenant porte des lunettes de soleil
et des t-shirts avec des têtes de mort
ça me dégoûte et à cause de la drogue le
cousin devenu irresponsable met le feu à
la maison c'est une catastrophe mon Dieu
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire les pompiers
appelez les pompiers il faut que
j'appelle l'assurance ah ben non tiens
il fait bon on va aller faire du vélo
plutôt allez viens cousine
on s'amuse bien non et tant qu'on fait
du vélo ça te dirait de prendre un peu
de merde enfin ça va vite là quand même
je veux dire c'est pas juste un pote un
peu défoncé à qui propose de fumer un
jouet c'est quelqu'un de sa famille
bonjour papi ça te dirait d'aller faire
du vélo hein et de prendre de la
DR regarde-moi ça il est tellement
défoncé que son t-shirt change de
couleur tout seul mais bon grâce à un
habile stratagème il réussit finalement
quand même à droguer sa cousine je sais
pas je je comprends pas je vois pas
d'explication il y a aucune raison pour
qu'il aille droguer comme ça sans raison
sa jolie cousine blonde
quoi vous êtes
dégueulasse bref pendant ce temps-là sur
l'île de l'espoir oui g révèle aux
planétaires les conséquences de la
drogue Washington a été détruite Seb tu
as pas vu ce qu'elle a dit ah ça va
c'est juste
ok les planétaires décident donc d'aller
aider ses pauvres victimes de la drogue
en les brûlant jusqu'au dernier Meur par
le feu sale
drogué et à partir de là cet épisode
devient un film de zombies les gens se
mettent à attaquer les planétaires le
cousin de la blonde se blesse en voulant
sauter par la fenêtre et se met à pisser
le sang là il y a le black qui vient
pour l'aider puis ah mais non il aide
pas en fait j'ai rien dit et finalement
à la fin de l'épisodevid le cousin de la
blonde comprend qu'en fait la drogue
c'est mal et a bien compris la leçon de
ne plus
recommencer je déconne il meurt dans
notre
souffrance c'est pas une blague il est
mort non mais genre mort pour de vrai
quoi je veux dire d'une overdose
en wouh je veux dire c'est la mort quoi
la vraie tu vois la mort quoi il aurait
juste pu je sais pas moi s'évanouir et
revenir à la fin de l'épisode pour dire
j'ai compris la leçon mais non ils
appellent captaine Planet et font ouais
vas-y captaine planette alors qu'il y a
encore le corps du cousin à ses pieds
puis finalement ils abandonnent son
cadavre sur la rambard d'un immeuble et
se barre enfin bref moral de cet épisode
ne vous droguez pas non ne déménager
jamais bref maintenant passons sur les
vrais super-héros ce des comics moi ce
que j'adorais c'était à quel point les
génériques de cette séries étaient
badasses
yeah
[Musique]
yeah voilà donc et pour cet épisode on
va repartir à une époque où les Russes
étaient encore des méchants la fin des
années 60 générique
[Musique]
les années 60 voi deux choses en
parallèle Hollywood se casse la gueule
et se voir remplacer par la
démocratisation de la télévision ce qui
explique la multiplication des séries
comme par exemple l'homme invincible
Iron Man Captain America notez
d'ailleurs que beaucoup de ces séries
étaient plus des motion comic c'est pas
vraiment des vrais dessins animés on
avait aussi les quatre fantastiques qui
est une série dont ben je vais pas
parler parce qu'elle est un peu chiante
par contre le générique des Quatre
Fantastiques
est
fantastique bravo
fantasti Richard
magique l'homme de Pierre Johnny la
torche hum su dans protecte l'image je
Paul et son
Maxime mais bon cette époque nous a
quand même donné des génériques et des
séries mémorables prenez le Spiderman de
67 par exemple très connu pour être une
énorme source de même sur le net en
chasse une fois de plus pour le journal
de Jameson des lumières mystérieuses
arrête de parler les seules lumières que
j'ai vu au loin sont des vers
luisants mettez vos ceintures arrête de
parler tout
seul la Brig les mystérieuses lumières
peut-être ta gueule ah mon Dieu je
déteste cette série qu les personnages
passent leur temps à faire des
monologues pour expliquer aux
spectateurs ce qui se passe ensuite elle
est vraiment très mal animé le seul
point positif c'est qu'on retrouve au
moins tous les personnages du comic
comme le Docteur Octopus dans son surv
Decathlon ou pierre parur oui pierre par
cur parce que les noms propres sont
traduits aussi si à ça en plus tu
rajoutes que la version française a été
doublée par des acteurs à qui on a
probablement volé leurs âmes trop tard
araigné tu le pas cher si tu lui fais du
mal octo araigné comment as-tu été
attrapé ah vous le sentez bien le danger
et la panique dans ce dialogue là enfin
bref donc cette série cumule les tard en
tout genre un GR Grou mes gens enfin
bref même si cette série était un peu
pas terrible au moins elle avait le
mérite d'essayer de respecter le com mix
puis arriva le
[Musique]
Japon enfin bref vous connaissez
l'histoire Peter Parker piqué par une
araignée radioactive donc qui obtient
les pouvoirs de Spiderman quoi c'est pas
ça et non c'est pas ça parce qu'on est
au Japon donc l'histoire commence dans
pass avec un vaisseau à tête de lion qui
s'appelle Marvel qui est observé par
deux extraterrestres qui veulent tuer le
professeur Yamashiro parce qu'il
pourrait découvrir la vérité que en fait
ce sont les dirigeants de l'armée de la
croix de fer qui projettent d'envahir la
Terre donc il y a la fille qui met une
chemise et qui récupère bkouryou le
petit robot dinosaure en pâte à modeler
pendant ce tempsl sur terre pendant le
tournage d'un
épisode ah silence ça assez compliqué
comme ça donc pendant ce tempslà sur
terre il y a le tournage d'un épisode de
turbo le vaisseau s'écrase dans une
montagne et puis il y a un mec qui
répare une moto et euh
attends mais c'est pas l'extraterrestre
attends pourquoi l'autre fait gen qu' la
connaelle qui éta dans le vaisseau il a
10 c'est qui
c
diff bon donc alors il y a les deux
filles qui sont par avec le vieux en
montagne pour chercher le robot géant du
début qui s écrasé suivi de la méchante
qui veut envahir la Terre et du
dinosaure en model pendant que le mec
qui fait de la moto il entend des voix
vous allez arrêter ces gros plans
ouais ensuite alors donc il y a le père
du héros dont j'ai oublié le nom enfin
je crois que c'est le père du héros qui
meurt et puis il rencontre un
extraterrestre qui meurt aussi et qui
lui demande de se venger du professeur
Monster dans son vaisseau spatial ok
donc le vaisseau extraterrestre c'est
dirigé par le professeur Monster
d'accord
c'est logique mais ça qu'est-ce que j'en
fous ah mais non ça y est regardez voilà
Spider-Man l'explication c'est qu'en
fait la planète des extraterrestres
s'appelle la planète araignée du coup
tout est parfaitement logique
[Musique]
maintenant bon de toute façon à partir
de ce moment-l l'épisode devient un mind
fuck
géant c'est quoi cette entrée de
[Musique]
champ et puis évidemment qui dit
Spider-Man dit robot géant donc il se
bat avec un robot géant et il repart
dans sa speeder voiture et puis voilà et
voilà fin de l'épisode alors bilan de
tout
ça excusez-moi vous êtes
japonais voilà on a parlé de Marvel
alors maintenant parlons de DC avec
Batman est probablement le super-héros
le plus aimé de tous les super-héros
Batman a eu énormément d'adaptations en
partant du BAT bat de 43 où Batman avait
un super costume en passant par la très
célèbre série des années 60 jusqu'au
dernierav de Batman qui continue à
sortir régulièrement d'ailleurs en
parlant de la série Batman des années 60
il a eu aussi un long métrage qui a été
fait dessus et je pense qu'il est quand
même important de vous en parler pour
que vous compreniez le chemin qui a été
fait entre
ça et ça rendez-vous bande crimin donc
le film commence par une voix qui nous
explique une arme a été capturée sur ce
bateau qu'on voit Batman et Robin décid
alors de partir à sa rescous pour ça ils
utilisent l'hélicoptère non le
batcoptère bon ok donc le batcopter donc
passe auudessus de Gotham tout le monde
est très content Robin en profite pour
draguer un peu les filles au passage ou
le mec plutôt on dirait enfin bref en
arrivant auudessus du bateau Batman
décide de sauter dessus en utilisant
l'échelle non la batte échelle c'est
qu'une échelle quoi tu le vois bien
mais d'une manière surprenante le bateau
disparaît et Batman se voit attaquer par
le requin le moins dangereux du
[Musique]
monde ne vous plaignez plus jamais d'un
film Batman après ça et là une bataille
épique s'enuitain sérieux ils aurai au
moins pu enlever les bruit de caoutchou
quand il tape dessus je sais pas bref
heureusement Batman a toujours dans son
hélicoptère son mon spray
anti-requin quoi c'est pas la peine de
me filmer qu'est-ce que vous voulez que
je rajoute c'est un spray
anti-requin et il en a même un pour les
baleines quoi le truc qui mange que du
plcton et là finalement le requin finit
par lâcher prise
et
explose la vache on en est qu'à la 9e
minute du film en plus retour à Gotham
donc où après la conférence de press
Batman Robin le commissaire Gordon et
l'autre mec que je sais pas qui c'est
décide de trouver qui est l'auteur de la
disparition de ce bateau et pour ça il
décide de consulter la liste des super
criminels en liberté en yant tous de
leur petit commenta au passage pingouin
ce monstre qui marche en canard en
faisant bouffer ses plumes brandissant
ses millions de paraplu
piég le Joker ce clown démoniaque prince
du crime si j'avais reçu un dollar
chaque fois qu'il m'a roulé et bien je
ser riche le SPX aussi est libre on
dirait libre de nous poser ses
épouvantables
énigmes ça alors la femme chat
est
mer après nous avons une des meilleures
scènes de déduction de ce film je
rappelle que Batman est censé être le
meilleur détectif du monde mais avant de
la regarder voici quelques consignes de
sécurité mesdames messieurs la scène qui
va suivre ne contient absolument aucune
logique avant de la visionner vous
pouvez déposer votre cerveau à droite ou
à gauche veuillez attacher votre
ceinture ça pourrait être l'un d'entre
eux mais voilà lequel mystère ou plutôt
lesquel pensons qu'un poisson m'a appé
le pied au-dessus de l'océan où il y a
du poisson on trouve des pingouins mais
attention le poisson et l'aliment des
chats c'est peut-être la femme chat oui
et ce requin piégé c'était un coup de
poker pour m'abattre le Joker tout cela
nous pose une terrible
énigme une énigme le
Sphinx quoi ah là là c'est un mauvais
jour pour Batman le super détectif qui
chute directement à la 8e place du
classement juste derrière Deric et
nester Burma tandis que les méchants
sont occupés à faire
les des trucs de méchant quoi Batman est
de retour à la Batcave où il découvre
que le faux bateau a été projeté depuis
une bouée tout ça grâce à la super
technologie de la Batcave 9b vite
programme notre calculatrice avec ses
facteurs
Roger je ne sais pas m'en servir Batman
bref Batman et Robin décident alors
d'aller vers la bouée en question pour y
trouver des indices mais les méchants
les y attendent dans leur sous-marins de
méchants avec des palmes piloté par des
pirates des pirates qui font Yoho angle
de Moné 30° monter 3 degr sur terre vous
pouvez commander en mer il vous faut
plier ah vos gueule et bref les méchants
donc utilisent un appareil pour
accrocher Batman et Robin à la bouée et
en profitent pour leur tirer des
missiles
[Musique]
dessus nonom d'une pipe mais qu'est-ce
qui arrive les forbant ils ont
transformer cette bouée en un
gigantesque
électroment nous sommes pris par les
boucles métalliques de nos ceintures
enlevez vos ceintures
oh une tpille
devant si j'arrive à inverser la
polarité et à lui opposer une super
énergie enlevez vos ceinture en voilà
encore une
[Musique]
Batman c'est bien notre veine n pas
triste sont cuites enlz vos
ceintures vous êtes qui
vous mais malheureusement les méchants
réussissent à toucher la bouée avec une
torpille qui explose avec Batman et
Robin
[Musique]
dessus surface monsieur bar surface
allonsère nos regards de cette
m ils sont mort j'espère je croise les
doigts
[Applaudissements]
ah Batman quelle noblesse dans le geste
chevalesque de ce marin
oui noblesse de la part de cet animal de
sêtre placé sur la trajectoire de cette
torpille il s'est sacrifié pour nous
[Musique]
retour sur la berge où Batman téléphone
à l'amiral pour lui demander s'il a
vendu un sous-marin
récemment un
marçin là est-ce que j'ai vendu un
sous-marin
récemment je suis idiot réponse
affirmative Batman nous disposions bien
d'un sous-marin des surplus jusqu'à
vendredi un modèle pré nucléaire merci
bien ça me suffit amplement 20000 sabor
Batman vous avez là tout à coup si am
mer avons-nous fait une bêtise par
hasard vous vendez un sous-marin
préatomique à une personne qui ne vous
laisse même pas son adresse mes
compliments
amiral mais allez on s'en fout parce que
pendant ce tempslà l'homme Mister l
adressé une nouvelle
énigme que fait un végétarien devant une
dinde bien risselée il l'avale goulument
quoi bien sûr et numéro 2 qui pèse 200 g
et dans un arbre est très dangereux un
moineau armé d'une
mitrailleuse deè chute consécutive pour
Batman qui repère encore trois places et
passe derrière l'Inspecteur Gadget
pendant ce tempsl les méchants
établissent un plan pour enlever Bruce
Wayne afin d'entirer Batman dans un
piège grâce à katuman qui doit draguer
Bruce Wayne lors d'une soirée ce dernier
accepte de sortir avec elle sans savoir
que c'est katuman évidemment mais
demande quand même à Robin et Alfred de
les suivre
[Musique]
attends
quoi est-ce que je viens de voir Alfred
tranquillement conduire la BAT mobile
devant tout le monde att excusez-moi
vous êes pas Alfred le majom de Bruce
Wayne
ou ça veut dire que Bruce Wayne est
batmanz
çaaire çaurait pu êre marin qui pilote
la Batmobile allez MOS vite fait
dur
madoiselle est-ce que vous me ferez
visiter votre superbe
[Musique]
appartementit allez donc pendant ce
temps dans la voiture
tu sais Robin ça fait longtemps que je
voulais te dire que je trouve tes
petites cuisses très
attiranteser des trucs ok c'est bon ça
va donc les méchants attaquent Bruce
Wayne qui leur décoche une réplique
singlante bande criminelle mais malgré
cette attaque verbale les méchants
réussissent quand même à le maîtriser
puis à
[Musique]
l'enlever pendant ce temps dans la
voiture arrête avec ça je t'ai dit ok ça
va ça va et donc là la nouvelle de ces
événements se répend partout dans le
monde non pas celle-là voilà celle-là
après l'avoir amamené au repère des
méchants Bruce réussit quand même à
s'échapper en évitant au passage un
piège du Joker d'ailleurs on apprend
visiblement que dans le monde de Batman
tout corps immergé dans la mer
explose moi après chaque cascade pour
reprendre des forces et me décontracter
je bois clip
n pour nous les cascadeur Bruce décide
de revenir en Batman là où il avait été
enlevé avant de constater qu'une bombe
s'apprête
explos après on a la fuse scè Batman
cour dans la rue avec une bombe une
scèult connue sur d'ailleurs et
finalement la bombe explose avec Batman
mais ne vous inquiétez pas les enfants
Batman n'est pas mort
[Musique]
Batman jeis voyez
pas regardez bien je suis là su vous
m'avez fait
peur bref après il se passe plein de
trucs il y a le pingouin qui vient la
bave pu qui s'échappe avec la BAT mobile
suivi par Batman et Robin qui le file en
hélico mais là il y a l'homme mystère
qui tre encore missile qui frle le
badcoptè qui tombe qui gigote qui se
retourne et qui s'écrase sur le sol si
vous aimez Batman faites qu'il Meur que
ça s'arrête ça alors
oh quelle veine atterrir sur un tapis de
caoutchou mousse ou
[Musique]
Robine je
suis bon maisant ça suffit hein j'ai
rien dit pour Alfred j'ai rien dit pour
le marin j'ai rien dit pour les énigmes
tu ref fais une seule connerie une seule
je me casse d'accord bon donc le film
reprend sur l'homme mystère qui envoie
oh non 17 oh non des pommes en compote
voyons c'est comme une sorte d'union par
le mélange un œuf c'est une merveille
naturelle il contient lui tout seul
l'espoir pour l'avenir quelque chose qui
représente l'union pour l'avenir
l'organisation du monde unique
précisément Robin et c'est la fin
aujourd'hui pour Batman qui repère
encore 23 places et passe derrière
scoobydooon allez stop c'est bon pour
moi c'est terminé de toute façon si je
voulais vous parler de tout ce film il
me faudrait 30 minutes de plus donc
voici la fin en mode abrégé les méchants
vont au siège de l'ONU desg tous les
diplomates qui s'enfichent complètement
vu qu'il Contin continuent à discuter
tout seul Batman et cour dev un fond
bleu les pirates font yo le mec qui
écrit les dialogue trou du cul PAF Bou
bom l'équipe du puis de fois gagné et là
Batman réalise que katuman était en fait
la nana qui voulait se taper 30 minutes
plus
tôt serait-ce possible mademoiselle
kitka
[Musique]
ch
vie finalement il récupère les
diplomates en poudre les retransformment
en humain se plant enversant leur corps
et leurs âmes et décident de se barrer
discros par la fenêtre avant de se faire
choper pour leurs conneries
partons mais sans nous faire
remarquer et voilà c'était Batman le
film des années 60 alors bilan de ce
film et bilan de tout cet épisode sur
les super-héros
trouvez le Joker les enfants trouvez-le
[Musique]